وانا احييكم من جديده
انا صديقتي ايران من النفط الخام قفزت الى
مستويات مرتفعه من دون نوفمبر الماضي لتصل
الى نحو مليون و300 الف برميل يوميا في
نوفمبر والده استقر شهر الماضي بالقرب من
اعلى مستوياتها في اربع سنوات القسم
الاكبر من النفط الايراني توجه الى الصين
اكبر مستوردا لنفسي في العالم خاصه بعد
تخلي بكين عن اغلاقات كورونا ارتفاع سطرات
النفط الايرانيه يوفر بعض الطمئنان لكل من
طهران وللسوق العالميه كذلك التي تخشى من
احتماليه تاثر الامدادات
الروسيه بالعقبات المفروضه على موسكو لكن
في الوقت نفسه لا يرضى او لا ترضى
الولايات المتحده وحلفاءها الذين يريدون
اسعار نفط اقل ويسعون ايضا الى حضر
الصادرات الايرانيه في اطار العقوبات على
طهران بسبب برنامج جهن
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
ديفيد بولو كالمستشاره السابق في وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه وكبير الباحثين في
معهد واشنطن لسياسه الشرق الادنى ومن
اثينا الدكتور عبد اللطيف درويش استاذ
الاقتصاد واداره الازمات في جامعه كرديف
اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام اسم حالي ان ابدا من
اثنا معك دكتور عبد اللطيف في الواقع
اسئله عديده بخصوص تحرك ايران الاخير
والتعاملها مع همم السوق بشكل عام
الباغ يرى حريه ويا راحه لنبالق بان ايران
تتعامل بطريقه شبه عاديه مع همم معادله
همم طلب همم
يعني صادرات والواردات هناك اسواق مفتوحه
في وجهها لتحقيق ااه هذه المبيعات
وبالتالي سؤال مطروح هل هذه العقوبات همم
اثرت تعتقد على ايران
طبعا هي اثرت على ايران ولكن دائما اي
الذي يعني تقع عليه العقوبات كما روسيا
ايضا يستفيد من الثغرات هناك
عدم اتفاق اوروبي بشكل عام باتجاه موضوع
ايران هناك حاجه وعطش اوروبي هناك جرت
عمليات تخزين واسعه للبترول والغاز في
اوروبا
فالحقيقه احنا هناك حاجه
للغاز والنفط الايراني
الدول العديده من الدول الاوروبيه تشتري
النقد الايراني وحتى النقط الروسي والغاز
الروسي والغاز الايراني
بطرق ملتويه من خلال شركات وهميه وشركه
افريقيا وشركات ترفع او سفن العالم
ليبيريا وما شبه او وما شبه ذلك فبالتالي
همم مستفيد ايضا صعب على همم على سبيل
المثال على موارج الامريكيه ان توقف سفينه
صينيه او سفينه روسيه
صغيره ولكن لا تستطيع ولا تتجرا
ايران تستفيد دائما من هذه الثغرات وايضا
ارتفاع الاسعار نتيجه حاله القلق في السوق
وتعطش السوق الى الطاقه فبالتالي هذه
الفرصه الايراني
ويبدو سيد بولوك بان هذا الموضوع يريح
كذلك الولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم بان
تكون هناك سوق موازيا للسوق الروسيه حتى
وان كان ذلك على حساب البرنامج النووي
الايراني هل هذا دقيق
همم بصراحه انا اعتقد انه انا اتفق مع
الزمالك انا اعتقد انه العقوبات بصراحه
كامله رمزيه الى حد ما ليست فعاليه همم
[موسيقى]
لغاز الطبيعي على الرغم من تلك العقوبات
لكن في نفس الوقت بتذكر انه القبات دار
الاقتصاد الايراني الى حد المقارنه همم ما
كان يحصل بدون
معنى انه هناك نوع من الضغط اقتصادي على
النظام في طيران ولكن هذا الضغط غير كافل
تغيير سياسه هذا العام الاسد الشديد
دكتور عبد لطيف همم ما الموقف الحقيقي اذا
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم مما يحدث
همم الى جانب همم برنامج ايران انا بمعنى
ان لما نرى التصريحات تصريحات واشنطن لا
تتقابل مع ما يطرحه ضيف او ما يصف بهذه
العقوبات بانها رمزيه البعض يصفه كذلك
بالناعمه
المسيرات الايراني التي استعملتها روسيا
فيها تكنولوجيا امريكيه ايضا في الجانب
الامريكي هناك اغراض الشركات الامريكيه
ممكن ان تكسر همم الحصار بشكل او باخر من
خلال القبائل الاقتصاديه المساله الدولار
هي اهم فبالتالي هناك طرق يعني الالتفاف
على هذه العقوبه همم وكما اسلفنا ان السوق
العالمي المتعطشه واعتقد ان موضوع الملف
الايراني بسبب ايضا همم صعود المساله
المساله اوكرانيا اكثر فبالتالي هناك
عمليه لنقل البصر عن موضوع همم العقوبات
الايرانيه او تخفيف منها لان ايضا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم تعطي
للاوروبيين لا بدائل لا للغاز ولا للنفط
ولا للقمر فبالتالي الاوروبيين بحاجه الى
الغاز
هناك التعاون بشكل اخر
سالتقد هذه الكلمه لانقلها لضيفي اا استاذ
بولوك الباز يقول بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مرتاحه لفتح سوق الموازيه للسوق
الروسي ولكن ابعد من ذلك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تحرك ايران تضغط
احيانا وتحاول ان تلين معه احيانا اخرى
بما يتوافق مع مصالح واشنطن ما رايك
الازدواجيه او حتى المؤامره الامريكيه مع
ايران انا وخالف في الشتاء على هذا
التقييم انا اعتقد انه لابد همم من كلنا
ان نعترف بان ايران واا الولايات
الامريكيه المتحده على الديوان همم بشكل
جاد ولذلك انا اعتقد ان صحيح هناك نعم من
السوق اسود
الامريكيه الى ايران لكن هذا غير شرعيه
الدكتور عبد اللطيف دكتور هل تتفق بان همم
واشنطن طهران عدوان حقيقان كما يصفهما
الاستاذ بلوك او هي صوره للترويش ولكن
حسابات شيء اخر
يعني كل دوله لديها اسلحتها ولكن اعتقد ان
الملائه في الايراني اخذ الصف الثاني بسبب
موضوع الروسي انا اريد ان اعطيكم مثل
الكون موجود باليونان تم احتجاز نفط
ايراني على
خارجه روسيه في اليونان ومن خلال احتجاز
اخرتين اضطرت اليونان للافراج عن كميه
النصر
والافراج عن السفينه فبالتالي كل دوله
ماذا فعل بالايران وهي مخالفه للقانون
الدولي
بتحمل النفط او الخليجي
فبالتالي لم يحدث
فعل اتجاه ايران فبالتالي اعتقد انا لا
اقول انهم حليتين هناك اختلافات ولكن
اعتقد انه هناك ساعي للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لاحتواء الموضوع الايراني كون
ان هناك اولويات واعتقد ان انا في رايي ان
هناك حسب معلومات لانه هكذا شركات امريكيه
تؤمن لايران ليس فقط العديد من السلاح ومن
ضمنها التكنولوجيا همم وقد لا يسعني همم
يعني المكان ان اذكر حتى موانع في المنطقه
يتم استعمالها لدعم ايران من خلال الشركات
الامريكيه اذا مثلا
ما اتفقتم عليه كون هذه العقوبات هي
عقوبات لا تؤثر بشكل لا يغير سلوك دوله
هنا يطرح سؤال ما مدى نجاحتها اتفقت مع
على ان هذه العقوبات اداه فاشله للضغط على
الدول يمكن ان تؤثر بنسبه ولكن لا تغير
سلوك الدوله وبالتالي همم
المنتظر من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
ظل ضعف هذه العقوبات من همم سلوك ايران في
المنطقه
لهذا السؤال
نموذج الاستثنائي لقباب ناجحه كان في فتره
الرئيس السابق رئيس اوباما والمفاوضات على
التقاط النووي الاصلي مع ايران
وسبب الرئيسي لنجاح هذه الاقبال في سنوات
2012 الى ااا
2015 لما بقيت ااا هذا الاتفاقيه مع ايران
سبب رئيسي لهذا النجاح كان الاجماع الدولي
المعنى مشاركه الصين وروسيا ودول اسيا
بشكل عام وجوه الاخرى طبعا دول اوروبا
بشكل عام المشاركه في كل الدول في قاره
هذه العقوبات على النظام في سهران في هذه
الفتره بدون هذا الاجماع الدول العقوبات
الاحذيه الامريكيه او الاوروبيه همم انا
اعتقد فاشله يعني هناك بديل لايران في
روسيا
وحتى الاسواق سوداء ولكن استاذ عبد اللطيف
هذه المعادله همم هل توحي بفشل امريكيين
نتحدث عن همم محدوديه هذه العقوبات هل هو
فشل امريكي ام همم هناك سياسه تعتمدها
ايران او بدات تعتمنها منذ
الضغط عليها من خلال هذه العقوبات فبدات
تتعامل بشكل مختلف اضاع حسابات واشنطن في
هذا الاطار
يعني حقيقه حين نقول موضوع فن اداره
الازمه والقدره على التحمل اعتقد ان
السياسه الايرانيه بطبيعتهم عندهم قدره
على التحمل وطول النفس والصمت والعمل في
صمت حقيقه او كما الصينيون في هذا الموضوع
والحقيقه هم نجحوا في اختراق هذه العقوبات
من خلال حسب
اسطولهم
الطيران كان يتجدد من خلال اوكرانيا على
سبيل المثال همم ايضا نفطهم غازهم يذهب من
خلال تركيا وهي دوله بالناردو وليس فقط
النفط والغاز الروسي هناك يعني ثغرات نجحت
ايران من خلالها ان تتحمل اولا وانت تقوم
باختراق لن اختراق هذه العقوبات وايضا
هناك اختلاف بين بشكل عام بين موقف
الامريكي
والموقف الاوروبي وحتى بين الدول الاوروبي
هناك اكثر الان خروج روسيا من يعني الى
بشكل
ايضا يضعف هذه العقوبات فاعتقد عمليه
اداره الازمه من نعم كانت افضل من ادارتها
امريكا
من اسينات دكتور عبد اللطيف درويش استاذ
الاقتصاد واداره الازمات في جامعه كارديف
ومن واشنطن ديفيد بلوك المستشار السابق في
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه وكبير الباحثين
في معهد واشنطن سياسات الشرق الادنى شكرا
لكما للنقاش دائما بقيه السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]